[Music]
so here in this video we will go back to
a field that we haven't touched in ages
and eons yeah we are back to Lovecraft
and this list right here is about the
most powerful outer gods in his works
and also in the later expanded cthul
mythus which includes daes from other
authors that join in to increase the
expansive Universe mind you we will rank
them as much as our understanding so as
to let you voice your own thoughts down
there so let's get to it number 10 abhat
the out God abhat isn't a creation of HP
Lovecraft but was included in the seven
geeses by clar Ashton Smith and it forms
a part of the larger cthul myths it is
described as a disgusting pool
surrounded by muddy edges it is a repuls
of gray mass that constantly grows and
gives rise to all sorts of deformed
creat creatures and monsters ranging
from limbs bodies to Rolling heads
swimming away from the God and becoming
increasingly monstrous as they move
farther if these creatures don't swim
quickly to the shore they will be eaten
by the mouths within the main M of
aboth number nine Dao another lesson
known out of God doolo as described in
ramse Campbell the render of the veils
is a complex and Indescribable entity
with hemispheres shining metal and
plastic rods forming an intricate
structure its appearance is so
perplexing that observers cannot discern
a specific shape and Summoners must
offer a small amount of blood to bring
it to the world without magical
containment doolo relentlessly expands
potentially at an infinite rate those
who are enveloped by doolo are
transported to a bizarre and remote
dimension of world often resulting in
their own
demise number eight Yip distal Yip
distal a monstrous deity in Earth's
dreamlands is an immense bad wied
humanite adored with a green rope this
horrific entity rotates slowly
overseeing all of time and space while
its eyes are detached and beneath its
flowing cloak and also numerous night
guns cling and suckle at its breast it
she has a significant connection with a
great old one called B shash aligning
itself with the drowners group
introduced by Brian Lumley these
parasitic alien entities Thrive by
draining the life force of the great old
one but in RPG materials yep distal is
then categorized as an outer
God number seven sh nurat sh narat
called the black godat of the woods with
a thousand young is an outer God first
appearing in Lovecraft revision Story
the last test of 1928 she is originally
never actually described but is
frequently mentioned or called upon in
incantations later on she is described
as an enormous Mass which extrudes black
tentacles also slamming dripping mouths
and short writhing goat legs small
creatures are continually spat forth by
the monstrosity which are either
consumed into the mastic form again or
they escape to for Monster life
elsewhere number six the darkness the
darkness is an outer God and the
progenitor of shab nurat Lovecraft
placed the darkness as an offspring
directly from azoto with nioep and
nameless Mist as the darkness siblings
in a dream quest of unknown kada Randolf
cter is described as falling through
endless voids of sentient Blackness it
is unknown if this is related to The
Entity named The Darkness or it might
just be an endless void nevertheless the
darkness is very powerful but yet it
exists in another
realm number five n lotp NP stands apart
from other Cosmic beings and other gods
here CU unlike those relegated to stars
or immersed in dreams netop is active
and and frequently roams Earth in human
guys often appearing as a tall slim and
a cheerful man with a myriad of other
horrifying forms while other Cosmic
entities are often described as mindless
niop is actively cruel deceptive
scheming and manipulative unlike the
different Natures of the other Cosmic
beings NP cultivates followers and uses
propaganda and Revels in cruelty to
achieve his goals serving the OU Gods he
is often their messenger embodying their
will and also acting as a servant to
aoth his father notably he is considered
as a sibling to Darkness and the
nameless Mist number four the nameless
Mist the nameless mist is an outer God
he is the progenitor of several other
Cosmic entities including the outer God
y soot it is older than everything
except for its creator AO and its
siblings who are the darkness the
unnamed darkness and nthp it spouse in
include possibly omnipresence reality
warping A causality Spacetime
manipulation immortality and incorpor
reality he is sometimes also known as
the Magnum innominat but this was later
W G by Lovecraft
himself number three gag zuk clot this
is an outer God and is The Offspring or
a son of aot by spontaneous fishion he
is the grandfather of satua gagot is
said to be superior to niop also
superior to the ultimate gods and the
nameless MTH and the Darkness uh the
nameless Mist which is the creator of
York soot zag zuk clot divided itself
into a masculine and feminine aspect the
masculine was called nug and a feminine
being was called YB and they produced
various other offsprings together later
on Gag Zuko resembled something of a
cross between aot and ubusa an amorphous
mass of bubbling nuclear and prot
plasmic gel number two yor sth yoro is
described as a collection of glowing
spheres it is an all- knowing Dey aware
of the past the present and the future
unlike other cthul Mythos deities yth is
connected to all time and space but at
the same time is supposedly locked out
of the universe it possesses complete
knowledge and understanding seeking to
Please yot may Grant access to a wealth
of information however as with many
entities in the myths encountering or
learning too much about it can lead to a
disastrous consequence and ultimate
Madness yot M it with Chap narat and had
offsprings including the twin deities no
and yeb and cthulu as well who was born
from n through pathog Genesis this out
God is sometimes called the most
powerful rivaling even ASO
himself and of course number one AO
sometimes called the blind idiot God or
sometimes also called as the demon
Sultan well there can be no definite
description of aoth because everybody
envisions him differently and also he's
always changing as described by
Lovecraft he is an amorphous blight of
nethermost confusion which blasphemes
and Bubbles at a center of all Infinity
it is said that we all exist in his
dream and if he was able to wake up then
everything in existence will vanish and
fade away as if nothing ever happened
while y s thought can be said to be the
most powerful by sheer force of will
aoo trumps this by erasing everything
that is by just waking up yet yot might
be the only OT the only one that can
survive since it is locked outside the
dream
universe and so those are the 10 most
powerful lovecrafting out the gods so if
you like this video then watch this
other one as well and if you're more
interested in other movie Monsters
content and creatures then check out our
Channel as well we might just have
things that you haven't seen or thought
about like subscribe and we'll see you
in the next video till next time take
care fam